twenty years after Princess Diana's
death we are hearing for the very first
time about the last time she spoke stew
her son's tonight in a new documentary
it's called Diana our mother her life
and legacy Prince William and Prince
Harry share their memories it debuts
tonight on HBO they also reveal regrets
over a phone call with Diana that they
had no idea would be their very last
Elizabeth Palmer's outside Kensington
Palace in London Liz good morning good
morning Kensington Palace behind me is
where Prince William and his family live
now but of course it's where Diana lived
too more than two decades ago and so
full of the kinds of memories and
recollections evoked in this documentary
a little bit to roll up into this point
it's still raw two decades after
Princess Diana's sudden and shocking
death her royal sons reminisce about
life with their famous mother she may
have been the most photographed woman in
the world but at home she was just mom
she was one of the naughtiest parents
she would come and watch us play
football and you know smuggle sweets
into her socks they remember to how she
loved to dress them up in silly costumes
and to snap family pictures we thought
you know I could've loved her night the
memories are inevitably bittersweet the
last time the princes spoke to their
mother she was in Paris hours before she
died and they were far away in Scotland
with their grandmother the Queen in a
hurry to go out and play Harry and I
were in a desperate rush to say goodbye
William says if I'd known what was going
to happen I wouldn't have been so blase
Harry who was then 12 said how
differently the conversation would have
panned out if he'd had the slightest
inkling it was to be their last now 35
years old
William is making sure that Lady Diana
is recognized as granny Diana by his own
two children I do regularly put in
Georgia charts bear talked about her and
just trying to remind her that some
there are two grandmother's there were
two grandmother's and in their lives
the princess hoped
mind a new generation that their mother
was more than a glamorous cover girl she
was a trailblazing celebrity activist
Roy Anika has seen the documentary
people now understand the work she did
pioneering work she did for things like
HIV and AIDS for homelessness for the
landmine campaign they want to introduce
her to a new audience we didn't know her
then the boys who knew her best have now
followed her lead to become public
champions for the vulnerable people with
mental health problems or injured
service a cause harry spoke to Norah
O'Donnell about last year I'd hope
you're being incredibly proud I hope you
should be sitting up there having our
little party and looking down thinking
you know what we've achieved because
there's a massive massive team effort
what we've achieved is absolutely
brilliant it's been clear for some time
how much the princes admired and
respected their mother's public activism
but what we're now learning is how much
in private they just adored her sheer
playfulness Jeff was a very nice it
really is it's so touching Charlie to
hear them speak about their mom after
all these years and to call her a
naughty parent also goes to show you
never know when it's going to be the
last conversation with someone I'm
struck by that it's too bad they feel so
badly about that because you do never
know right yeah
she clearly adored them and they her
good to see